okay welcome everyone
my name is tim mcdevitt i'm a part-time
developer on the visualization team at
wolfram
and today i'm going to take you on a
tour of the complex visualization
functions that are new in version 12.
all right so anyway so here on the left
is a picture from maxwell's treatise on
e
m in 1873. it's a picture of a
capacitor the two parallel lines they
represent a capacitor
along with electric field lines and
equipotential surfaces and so the
picture on the right is a recreation of
that using complex contour plot
and you know this is easy to generate
with just a few lines of code and so i'm
going to
show you this as well as a number of
other things
so the new functions in particular are
listed here some of them are new in
version 12.0
some in 12.1 and then 12.2 we'll see
complex array plot for the first time
so the first function i'm going to talk
about is complex list plot
this works much like list plot except
that the data are complex valued so here
you're just looking at 50
random values sort of in the unit square
in the complex plane and
it basically does what you think complex
list plot
would do a nice application for this
might be if you're looking at the
eigenvalues of a matrix
frequently they turn out to be complex
valued and a complex list plot is a nice
tool for that
here you have an example of a 500 by 500
matrix with random entries
uniformly distributed on -11 and you can
see the eigenvalues all live inside of a
circle
so this is sort of a famous circle law
for
random eigenvalues or eigenvalues of
random matrices
another nice application that i like is
being able to label eigenvalues with
their corresponding eigenvectors
so here we have a three by three fourier
matrix
i compute the eigenvalues and
eigenvectors using eigensystem
and i make what i call images here but
it's basically just a matrix form of the
eigenvectors
and then using complex list plot i'm
able to
display the eigenvalues very easily in
the complex plane along with labels
showing the corresponding eigenvectors
all right and then just for fun i also
changed the theme so i think that's a
nice application
and if you're solving an equation or a
system of equations
you might have complex solutions so
here's one
sine of z cubed minus one this can be
solved basically by hand but
solutions look like you see here in the
picture i made them
the the dots into stars just for fun i
want this to sort of be a memorable
figure because i'm going to return to
this problem
when i discuss complex array plot so i
want you to remember this
so so i made everything sort of red
white and blue just so it sort of stands
out
notice that all of the solutions to this
problem live
on one of six rays emanating from the
origin so there's
six different angles here that
correspond to solutions of the equation
we're looking at
which isn't terribly important but it's
sine of z cubed minus 1 again
and then i've also highlighted some of
the options
that are sort of distinctive to complex
list plot as opposed
to list plot in particular the ones that
begin with the word polar so polar axes
polar ticks polar axis origin
polar grid lines in a complex context
things are often sort of origin centered
and a lot of times it's nice to be able
to sort of use these sort of polar
features so anyway for this picture
remember that the solutions there are
just six different angles
but there's an infinite number of
solutions along each of the spokes
sort of emanating out from the origin
here
okay the next function is reimplot
re-implot
takes a function well the input is a is
a real variable and the output
is in general a complex variable
or a complex valued function and so you
can see on the left we have the standard
plot of the arcsin function
which you know the first time a student
runs into this in precalculus or trig
class or whatever
they're told that this is only defined
from minus pi over two to pi over two
and if you construct the plot with the
plot function in the wolfram language
that's what you get because it ignores
anything that's
non-real however if you use reimplot
and plot the same function you can see
in the middle of the graph it looks the
same from minus pi over two to pi over
two
but the reimplot plots the real part
with the solid
curve and then the imaginary part either
dotted or dashed there
right and so you can see the sort of
extension of
the arc sine function out of the minus
pi over 2 to pi over 2 interval
so it's just a little bit more the
output's just a little bit richer than
it is with regular plot and so sometimes
that's helpful
so one time that's helpful is say if
you're working with fourier transforms
so fourier transforms themselves can be
truly real or purely imaginary
um and sometimes a mix so this
particular fourier transform is
is mixed um so you can see with reimplot
you can easily see both the real and
imaginary parts
uh quite clearly and then with plot
labels you can label the two
components you can also do the labeling
with a legend instead
so plot legends goes to automatic gives
you the um
the corresponding labeling and then i'm
also showing you here two distinctive
options reim style
and reim labels so reim style allows you
to style the real and imaginary parts
of the um of the function and then reim
labels allows you to change the way the
labels are displayed
abzardplot is sort of similar to
reimplot
it's a it's a complex valued function of
a real variable
and so again here we use arcsine as a as
an example
so on the left you have the standard
plot of arc sine of x
and on the right you have abs arg plot
um abzar plot plots uh the
modulus of the function as a function of
x so that's why it's always positive
and then it colors the curve by the
modulus of the function all right and
the colors are indicated in the
corresponding legend
so you can see in the legend where the
angle is zero
the color is red and then like where the
um
angle is pi or maybe minus pi it's like
cyan or something like that
so if you look at the regular arc sine
plot
where it's real and positive it's
plotted in red
in the arc in the absurd plot and where
the regular arc sine is real but
negative it's plotted in cyan
in the absurd plot okay and then uh
elsewhere
the um the the arcsin function is is not
purely real and so you get more colors
then
okay so sort of similar functionality as
re-implod
and again this can be helpful when
you're working with fourier transforms
oftentimes with a fourier transform what
we usually plot is just the magnitude
um so you can do that very easily with
absorb plot but at the same time you
don't lose
the angle information because it's
present there in the color
okay next up we have complex plot and
complex plot 3d here we have a complex
value
function of a complex variable that
we're trying to represent
and so so sort of have a two dimensional
input and a two dimensional output and
we need to try to represent that
in a two-dimensional image so what we do
is we take the domain of a function or a
subset of the domain of a function
and we color it by the argument of the
function value at each point
right so if you look at the first image
on the left
you see where all the points i'm sorry
all the colors sort of come together at
the central point
so when when that happens when you have
a sort of convergence of these colors
that means you have either a zero or a
pole
in this case you have a simple zero and
you can tell that simply from the color
because if you say start where the red
is like sort of the red ray that sort of
points to the right
um if you then follow the colors of the
spectrum
you know roygbiv red orange yellow green
blue indigo violet
you move in a counterclockwise fashion
around the central point
and that tells you that you're looking
at a simple zero
if you look at the second figure it has
the same orientation if you pick one of
the red rays
and move in a counterclockwise fashion
you see a move through the spectrum in
the standard roy g bib sort of order
but there's sort of three red or three
cyan or three yellow or whatever rays
emanating from that central point and so
you can tell that this is actually a
triple zero
the third figure is uh you can tell that
that's a pole
because the orientation is is clockwise
so if you start where the red is
and follow roy g biv you you have to
move in a clockwise fashion so that
tells you that's a pole
and since you only go around one time to
go from red to red that's a simple pole
the fourth image this is a multiple pole
a triple pole because you have the three
red rays let's say
emanating from the central point and the
clockwise orientation and then in the
fifth image we have a picture of a
of an essential singularity which i'm
not really going to talk about today
because those get
those get pretty crazy so i'm going to
talk about these three functions here
um sort of over and over again all right
so you don't need to memorize them but
you know might be handy to sort of take
a peek at them
so you can see that f and h are both
rational functions
g isn't rational it's got this sinc
function in there
all right but if we take a closer look
at f you can see that there's a
quintuple zero
at the origin that there is a
simple zero at plus and minus two and a
simple pole at plus and minus two i
so if we do complex plot of that
function
we can see all of those features simply
from the color
all right so like if i start at this
point here where i see the colors
converging
all the colors come together here and i
start where it's red and i go around
rigi biv red orange yellow green blue
and go violet come back around
i can tell that has a counterclockwise
orientation so even without knowing the
formula for f i can tell that there's a
simple zero here
the same thing is true over here at the
central point at the origin
i have the same orientation if i start
where it's red
red orange yellow green blue indigo
violet brings me back to red here so i
have a
counterclockwise orientation so this is
a zero and then there's one
two three four five red rays emanating
from that point
so i know that's a quintuple zero simply
from the color
if we come up here we see more
information than was present in the
images above okay and so
the actual complex plot doesn't just
plot the mod i'm sorry
plot the argument with color but it also
plots the modulus of the function by
shading so you can see that represented
here in sort of the double legend
so where the um where the shading makes
the image
perfectly white that's a point at
infinity that's a pole
so we can tell there's a pole here and
here simply from the shading
or you can tell simply from the color so
if we start where it's red and we go roy
g biv
red orange yellow green blue and nega
violet and back to red
we can tell that has a clockwise
orientation so this is a simple pole
and the same thing is true down here so
you can tell those are simple poles
either from the the colors or from the
shading
now with complex plot 3d we do much the
same thing
except instead of shading the surface to
indicate the modulus of the function
we uh we use the third dimension and so
you can see the shading here
looks pretty much like the one above
the colors are pretty much the same and
then the the fact that we have poles
here you can see because
you have these two things that look kind
of like chimneys sticking up out of
out of the surface and so that's another
another way of visualizing one of these
complex functions
if in version 12.1 we
now have this shorthand notation if this
isn't familiar this is
z going from minus 3 minus 3i to 3 plus
3i so it's a shorthand way of
plotting images that are sort of
centered around the origin
now in terms of options for complex plot
and complex plot 3d
one thing you can change is the color
function now that's not distinctive
to complex plot but it is pretty handy
here
so this is the same function f okay
plotted over the same domain
but i chose the cm yk colors color
function
and the reason i chose that was i wanted
to have uh
say the branch cuts stand out so here
unlike the default color function
at minus pi this is blue or cyan or
whatever color that is
and up here where the angle is pi it's
black and so wherever we have a
transition from blue to black
that that indicates a branch cut right
and so you can clearly see the branch
cuts
in the image okay because of the choice
of color function
now something that is sort of
distinctive to these complex plots
is the shading functions that are
available and so there's a number of
named strings like this
that one can use to augment
an image so here i've chosen to show
cyclic log abs arc
and what this does is it cyclically
shades
both in the direction of the modulus or
the abs
and also in the direction of the
argument and you can see that reflected
both in the double legend
and then also in the graph
excuse me and so the effect of this is
is
it basically through the shading makes
it look like you have a mesh on the
surface
or you know both in the uh so it looks
like you have curves of constant modulus
and curves of constant argument
all right and we use log abs because
with complex value functions you
frequently have poles and so the log
keeps the shading
so things sort of look better most of
the time if you scale
the modulus by by the log
we also again we have a number of these
shading strings here's sort of a funky
one sick click rem log abs
so the the real and imaginary part here
gives you the black curves that you see
sort of underneath
and that looks like a mesh based on the
real and imaginary parts of g of z
and uh the white lines the bright white
lines
are like look like contours based on the
modulus or the abs of the function
here's another one shifted cyclic log
abs
characteristic of this shading function
is around any zero you tend to get a
little color wheel
okay like so here you can see three
simple zeros
and then around a pole you tend to get
concentric rings like that
now if you don't want to do shading of
course you can always add a mesh just
like in a lot of our other functions so
you can either have a mesh that
you put in explicitly or it can be sort
of implied through the shading
now complex array plot will be new in
12.2
all right and so it functions largely
like array plot except it works on
complex data
so here we just have you know some
random complex numbers
and the way they're represented unlike
array plot is not with with grayscale
but with
color and this is the same shading um
coloring scheme and shading scheme
that's used in complex plot
so that's not terribly obvious to you
from this particular graphic
um so here oh sorry so here i'm just
using some options i turn the mesh on so
you can see the
little gray lines between the cells i
change the color function
and none here turns off the shading so
there's no modular base shading here
but just to show you that this is the
same shading scheme as
complex plot i'm going to use complex
array plot to more or less regenerate
the image we saw previously of that
function f
so i'm going to make a table here of
f on a grid i wanted it to be a fine
enough grid that you could
realize that this is the same function
or the same plot as before
but not so fine that it's
indistinguishable from indistinguishable
from the complex plot version
so the coloring scheme is the same
both with the color for the argument and
the shading for the modulus
right now one difference here is when um
when table hits the the singularity or
the pole
we get a non-numeric uh entry in our
table and so that's shown here with that
sort of
maroon color that we use for either
missing values or non-numeric values
and if you want to get rid of that you
can just replace color rules
with color rules you can replace complex
infinity with white
and then this will look pretty much like
complex plot and if you
take smaller steps here you won't be
able to tell the difference between this
and a complex plot of the same function
some potential uses for complex array
plot one that i like here
is allows me to visualize the structure
of a fourier matrix
so here's a 16 by 16 fourier matrix and
i've turned off the shading
because i want to highlight a couple of
features here first of all
this has the same color scheme uh as
abzard plot so
wherever it was purely real and positive
everything's red so you can see on the
left and top margins here of the um
matrix
you have all red and then down the
center stripe
both vertically and horizontally you can
see
alternating red and i guess cyan right
and so it's alternating positive
negative positive negative
uh through the middle both vertically
and horizontally
and then elsewhere in the matrix we have
complex values okay as indicated by the
different colors
all right and then here i use say color
rules
to allow me to replace a
all the real values with black and all
the purely imaginary values with white
so again you can see the structure quite
clearly
of a fourier matrix
i think a nice application of this also
is for demonstrating basins of
attraction for
iterative methods so i'm returning here
to this function we looked at before
so remember this was the one that was
all red white and blue with the stars
with complex list plot
and remember all of the solutions uh
lived along one of three i'm sorry six
different rays
out coming out of the origin so there
are six different angles
so all the basins of attraction there
should only be six different colors
okay based on that all right and so here
i'm using newton's method
for this function and i generate a bunch
of
values and i plot them with complex
array plot
so there's really only six colors in
this picture corresponding to the six
angles in the image that i showed you
previously
um but i i added a shading function here
that i thought was a nice touch
because uh this is going to make some
distinctions
in magnitude right and so even though
there's only six different angles
there's an infinity of solutions
along those six different rays and so
the cyclic log ad shading helps us see
that a little bit
you know plus i think it looks pretty
cool
okay a complex vector plot and complex
stream plot
were introduced in 12.1 they're going to
be upgraded in 12.2
they're going to inherit the new
features that vector plot and stream
plot have
and you might have heard mins talk about
that about an hour or so ago
but basically here we're going to try to
represent functions complex valued
functions of complex variables again
just like complex plot
and so to get us started i've
superimposed uh
complex vector plots in the top and
complex string plots below
over a corresponding complex plot and so
at a point where you have a simple zero
you will see the arrows or the streams
either being
repelled from that point or being
absorbed into the point
if you have a multiple zero you will see
uh either the arrows or the streams
being pushed away and then being pulled
back
into the multiple zero and if you have a
pole you'll have saddle behavior so
you'll be
the streams or the vectors will be
attracted in one direction and repelled
in another
okay like this and if you have a
multiple pole
you know that same sort of thing you'll
have sort of a multiple saddles so to
speak
so this gives us another way of looking
at complex functions
all right so here we're looking at a
complex vector plot on the left and a
complex
stream plot on the right of that same
function f that we looked at before
i do want to point out now the color
means something different
the color here is a representation of
the magnitude of the vector field now
the vector field is the real and
imaginary parts of the complex function
f okay so in complex plot the color
was the argument and here it's it's
really the magnitude of the vector field
or the
the abs or the modulus of the function
um in both cases i bumped up the uh the
vector points and the stream points
because this is sort of a busy function
and so you can see this is another way
of representing these complex functions
and it's a little easier if you add some
labels which i did with complex plot
so like if you look at these two zeros
here you can see
this is this is a repulsive zero all the
arrows are sort of pointing away from
here and pointing away from here
at the center it's probably easier to
look at the stream plot
so you can see the streams being pushed
away and being pulled back to the
central point
pushed away and pulled back and at the
poles you can see saddle behavior right
being
pulled in and then pushed away pulled
and pushed away both at that pole
and at that pole all right so this is
another way of trying to visualize a
four dimensional thing here
in in only two dimensions um
sorry uh streamlines uh are going to
tend to be discontinuous
at branch cuts like you see here for the
log the um
you know they're basically being
repulsed in both directions here
um some of the options here again
there's going to be new options
that correspond to the new options for
vector plot
here so here i'm computing the poles and
zeros of this function h
and then i'm going to plot uh h along
with the poles being marked using
complex list plot
and so like if you look here you can see
this point here looks like a repulsive
point and this is repulsive and this is
attractive
right but these are three simple zeros
you can tell
and then here we have a simple poll
because we're being we have saddle
behavior where
you know the arrows are being drawn in
and then sort of pushed away
and you can see the same thing over here
in
the complex stream plot version of the
same function
okay so um something to point out here
to style the vectors or the streams to
make them orange i have to turn the
vector color function off
or the string color function off because
those the color functions have
precedence over
stream style and vector style and so
unlike in the past
the streams and the color and the
vectors weren't [ __ ] weren't colored
now they are by default and so if you
want to change it to your own color you
have to
you have to turn off the color function
i do want to point out here
that the vector fields still look good
even in the presence of poles
if you're used to using vector plot sort
of in versions prior to 12.2
if you have a singularity in your
function oftentimes
the behavior near the singularity
dominates the scaling for the whole
graph
and the vectors don't look always look
very good but in the upgraded
vector plot i think it look they look
pretty darn good and one of the things
that's done
here is the arrows all have the same
length by default now you can change
that but that's a new feature
and that's inherited here in complex
vector plot
and so when you have a pole like we have
here at the origin again you can tell
because of the saddle behavior
you know the the graph still looks
really good
another new feature of the vector plots
is that the points are not
the vectors are not laid out on a
rectangular grid but instead on a
hexagonal grid so we can pack more
vectors into the same area
okay and again you have the same options
here for complex vector plot for
changing the vector appearance
that you have for the new vector plot
options so we have vector scaling so if
you
if you want the vectors to be scaled
base based on their length you can
change that
vector range here is is specifying that
only vectors with lengths
uh or norms between two and ten should
be displayed
um and then they're when the they're
clipped so that they're not shown at all
so
you can see near the near the zeros and
near the pole they're clipped there's no
arrows being shown
the vector sizes here basically if the
vector sizes are all one
then that sort of gives you the maximal
hexagonal packing
all right and then point one will be ten
percent of that so you can scale the
actual sizes of the arrows
so you can control all of that just like
you can
in vector plot here in complex vector
plot
and then let's see so running out of
time
a nice application for this i think is a
polio plot
so for a polio plot if you want to do a
contour integral you can interpret the
output or the result of the integral as
the real part as the work done
and the and the imaginary part as the
flux of the corresponding polio field
which is basically just the conjugate
field
through the curve so if you look at the
red curve c1
you can see it's always orthogonal to
the to the field to the polio field
and so there's no work done by the field
there is however flux through the curve
and so that's a purely imaginary
integral as you can see in the legend
the green curve by in contrast is
parallel to the field and so the field
does do work along that but there's no
flux
and so that's a purely real result
whereas the blue curve
the field does both work and there is
flux through it and so you get a
a real and imaginary part for that
contour integral
see complex region plot largely the same
as region plot except you have a
complex variable for your domain and you
can plot
multiple regions pretty easily some nice
applications here
showing regions of convergence
and i'm going to go a little quicker
because i'm running out of time and then
if you want to do
complex transformations a lot of times
you know people restrict themselves to
looking at
you know where lines go under the
transformation or circles go under a
transformation here you can pick all
kinds of stuff
and then finally complex contour plot
you can have a real function here in
this case it's the modulus of h
so it's a real valued function of a
complex variable and it makes a contour
plot for you
and if you you can change options and if
you specify more than one function like
abs
here it automatically suppresses the
shading and just gives you
basically level curves of the modulus
and the argument of h
and then down here i did re-m of the
same function
right and then to close without running
over time again it just takes a few
lines of code with complex contour plot
to recreate maxwell's well-known image
from his treatise on e
m and so with that i
am done and i will try to answer any
questions that you have
um i i don't know what's in the beta
version i assume this is all in there
but i don't know for sure
yeah these complex things are fun all
right well thank you all for coming
i hope you enjoy the complex
functionality